Melissa, thanks for doing this.
Thanks Conan,
thanks for having me.
(laughing)
We have a lot to talk about,
I've been wanting to
talk to you for a while.
You've been obviously
killing it on a Senate Live.
You're so funny.
You do such amazing impressions,
the latest I'm told is Lin-Manuel Miranda.
You're working on a Lin-Manuel Miranda.
This is you in your,
in your makeup as Lin-Manuel Miranda
Yeah.
and if I'm not mistaken,
you just took a ballpoint
pen to your face?
(laughing)
Is that what you did?
Well, no, no, no.
That, that is eyeliner
and I, I always know that
it looks really good.
I mean, it doesn't look realistic,
but I'm saying that's what,
that's all I had on me, okay.
Okay, okay.
(laughing)
No, I, I like it.
I'm just gonna tell you in real life
and you probably have too,
I've spent time with Lin-Manuel Miranda
and in real life he uses a ballpoint pen.
Oh okay, well good, good.
Yeah, so that's what he does.
And he just fills it
in throughout the day.
What is the key to,
I don't know that I've heard someone do
a Lin-Manuel Miranda impression,
what's the key?
How do you hone in on that?
Well, I was thinking about it,
the way he sings,
it sounds like he's in the
sea and he's drowning, okay
and he's telling a boat nearby saying,
please hand me a lifesaver.
I'm drowning,
I just want to live with you
(laughing)
and so that's all,
right or is slipping off a,
a rope maybe?
Yeah.
No, I love you.
Don't let go.
(laughing)
Do you sing some of the actual songs
that he sings in Hamilton?
No, no, I have been singing my shot,
but the problem is I
don't know all the lyrics,
but I wanna sing it
real fast, like he does.
Right.
And I was trying to sing it
to my sister the other day,
I was like,
♪ I am not throwing away my shot ♪
♪ And yo I'm just like my country ♪
♪ I'm young scrappy and homie ♪
And I said, homie,
and she's--
Homie?
(laughing)
Hungry, it's hungry.
It's hungry.
(laughing)
Have you tried this out
on Lin-Manuel Miranda?
No, but he saw,
I shared a photo of that,
oh no, the video of me,
I went to, I drove through a,
a coffee place and I said,
I'll take a cold brew with a shot
and I filmed, it was so stupid, but he,
(laughing)
he messaged me he laughed so that was--
Those are my favorite,
my favorite impressions
are the silly ones,
do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
The one's where it's just like
you're using it in a completely
ridiculous, absurd way.
Getting a, getting a Starbucks order.